i tried to roller skate in a buffalo
herd too what is that it's a roger
miller song that i tried to bring to
life you tried to roller skate into a
buffalo yeah all right and and what
happened there well
roger miller was absolutely correct you
cannot roller skate in a buffalo hurt
they knocked the cow walking [ __ ] out of
me
[Music]
you had perhaps my worst fear and every
guy's worst fear happened to you do you
know what i'm talking about yeah yeah
you burned your [ __ ] and balls yeah yeah
you were working on a movie called the
eagle right the scottish highlands it
was freezing out the way i understand it
and it was so cold that a lot of the
guys would take warm water and pour it
down their pants
some [ __ ] uh handed you uh the cup of
warm water that you could pour down your
pants except he forgot to tell you that
it was scalding hot water scalding hot
right yeah boiling boiling uh what
happened next
uh i started hyperventilating and
screaming and jumping into back into the
river because it was a hypothermic river
and we had wetsuits on which is the
worst part about it and uh and so
this poor guy though i gotta be honest
poor guy look i i i know i know but he
had been for 13 hours running up a hill
for like 15 minutes like to boil this
huge like bottle of water fill it half
full with like actual kettle water
run back down the muddy hill and then
fill up the like put the river water in
it and then come over to me just to keep
me warm
right and then what we wrapped the day i
started walking up the hill and what had
happened he just didn't get all the way
down right so we had been 13 hours of
the same thing every time we saw each
other and he's like you want to warm up
for the walk uh for the walk up and and
of course i was like yeah why not and uh
just oh it was it was the worst thing
how long does it take like when you know
when you burn your finger and it just
keeps burning
it it kept burning for the next like
probably 20 to 30 minutes like i was
having a complete panic attack yeah
because you think you're losing your
dick yeah well
that was one one of the ambulance dudes
uh he was like he was like look man i
know this is no [ __ ] consolation i
can't do a scottish accent uh he's like
i know this is
i know there's no consolation now mate
but uh it's a good thing that it hurts
otherwise you've got nerve damage
i couldn't even i just couldn't and then
there happened to be a radio playing and
um i'll give you three guesses if you
haven't read it in an interview already
what song it was on what was it my your
sex is on fire oh no come on i swear to
you that is [ __ ] crazy that is
the actual song the driver was like
maybe we should change this no how long
does it take for that to heal where you
can actually bang again uh i would say i
was i was good almost a week later yeah
a week you were banging again yeah wow
yeah i mean look it wasn't it was it was
a little rough but we got we got it done
tell you something that's very masculine
i'll be honest i i do i think i've never
used yours
i'm such a baby i'm such a baby if i
burn my [ __ ] like that i'd wait a year
you can still be complaining you don't
remind you of like wolverine maybe uh
you know the way you did
are you circumcised uh yes you are yes
and it's still healed that fast still
healed that fast i would think
foreign like the head and everything
everything yeah that's the best part i
got it i got to be honest
the doctor gave me these bandages and i
was like okay cool so i put the bandages
around it
and i didn't think that you know i
didn't put any of that gauze or whatever
oh no i went down to the bar like the
next day and uh i was having drinking
beer and then and the next thing you
know you gotta you gotta go to the
bathroom yeah you gotta take a peek and
uh so i went to the bathroom and i
realized that i i i didn't get all the
tape on to the gauze like i
so it was on the bottom it was and i'm
sorry
basically on my knees in a bathroom in a
pub like in in scotland oh it's so sad
like i'm peeing in my triple burnt penis
like
and i was just like
i love the intensity than g.i jane that
you went and trained with the navy seals
like they say that training most people
crumble it was hardcore i mean we
obviously ours was modified but we had
all real seals down there those are
hardcore and it was me and 40 guys and
i'm telling you i went down to start the
training and i had stuff hanging in the
closet what is the training exactly well
i mean the first day
they had boots and the whole thing for
me and they made us do a mile run
off the bat five in the morning
i had taken some vitamins on an empty
stomach stupid
hall ass mile run straight out me 40
guys
and i like cross the finish line
literally take a right turn puke my guts
out like go get back in there like okay
so by midday we take a break they're
gonna put us in water so you're doing
everything these guys yeah the other
actors extras were all there to kind of
you know bond and learn the experience i
take my shoes off and i have these
massive blisters and harry humphries our
consultant
he said you know you don't really have
to do all this and i thought
if i don't right now
i'll never get it back i'll never get it
back
of you know the respect i'm playing an
officer like i was like ah you know just
give me some tape and i taped
up my you know blisters
and off we went i mean and they never
called me by my real name always by the
character name and i'm telling you they
set me up i'm convinced to be
late the first day the second day so
they could ream you and they and i
everyone was in formation and i'm like
i'm going to squeak in back in the back
and all of a sudden i hear
jordan front and center and i'm like
i like go up the front
and i'm like standing there and he says
drop your [ __ ] ass down right now and
i'm like oh wow okay uh do you have to
give him push-ups oh he said drop me
down into a lean and rest which is like
a push-up position
and oh he was screaming at me who the
[ __ ] do you think you are you think
we're gonna let some split tail come in
here drop your [ __ ] ass down i was
like
okay
jesus and then i like go in and then he
screams at everybody else
and they don't leave here you don't
leave a man behind you drop your asses
down so then now i'm responsible for
everybody else being in trouble oh my
god oh yeah that was but but the
instructor was impressed with you yeah
you had trouble with pull-ups yeah but
the instructor would say this woman's
had three kids you [ __ ] better
do it because you were really you were
nailing it
you do all your own stunts huh didn't
you break everything yeah i just broke
both my arms uh like what movie was that
it's a movie called tag it's a sort of
action comedy sort of thing and how do
you break both your arms in that moment
fell like 20 feet off a stack of chairs
did you need to do that stunt um you can
see my face my body doing a stunt yeah
yeah so that's important to you that's
important that's like jackie chan [ __ ]
right i mean like he does all his own
stuff yeah yeah i suppose you know it's
just uh you know you spend so much time
and money to try to create a world for
people to go sit down in the chair and
watch a movie you don't want him to like
be pulled out of a movie because you
know he's some
guy with a bad wig trying to do the
stunt but does the director ever say to
you listen we can get the coverage on
this thing like when you're making a
wind river that which we'll talk about
the new movie i saw this great movie
when you were making that movie you
you're driving around on a um like one
of those snow what do you call a
snowmobile
snowmobile you drove that snowmobile
yourself right yeah all
of them except for the big wide shots um
because we only had x amount of days to
really kind of uh
shoot this little independent movie so
and that's you uh driving it around
except earlier the big wide shots and
the guy really kind of getting after it
um otherwise but does the director of
mercedes listen we need you in the movie
if you break your head i would think it
would would cancel the whole movie yeah
i just wouldn't do something that where
i would break my head and elizabeth
olsen who's in that movie with you yeah
she's on the back of this uh
snowmobile yeah and she's like yelling
at you to slow down because you're crazy
there's stuff there's stuff for uh not
crazy
i just know my limitations uh it's the
same like with rachel vice on in born
legacy it's on that motorcycle it's like
you're on a on two wheels and slippy
road and you know you just got to be
careful because you are responsible for
somebody else's well-being you did those
stunts on born legacy right yeah yeah
geez you're out of your mind it's just
yeah you think you got a death wish or
something no not at all it's the only
time i ever got injured was in this
comedy
that stupid comedy you mean you mean
it's crazy
what do you do after you break both your
arms are you still gonna be able to work
yeah look i yeah i broke both of my arms
i got back up and i did the stunt again
get out of here oh my god on lunch i
went to the hospital i said yeah that's
broken that's broken and i went back to
work how do you how do you how many
weeks are you in cast from breaking bad
you were supposed to be by like around
four to six weeks i think um but i was
in splints so i could um not have the
tendons and ligaments everything kind of
lock up and let me ask you a a question
no one's probably ever asked you if you
make duty
and you have both arms broken yeah how
do you wipe your ass i got by did you
yeah you were able to do it i was able
to do it yeah the right the left wrist
was all right i was hanging in there no
kidding yeah but a lot of people thought
you know yeah what's he gonna do
yeah no that was my first thought like i
don't even know how you get dressed if
you have both arms broken that i
couldn't do you couldn't no no no people
have to dress you yeah that's where you
feel like oh my god i'm 90.
now you know people like tying my shoes
zipping up my fly oh my god bloody my
pants i'm like this is pathetic but i'd
still go out and go to work dude you're
something else 175 out cue you can zip
up your pants almost everything can take
a dump with both arms broken
incredible bowling skills i'm gonna put
this in my resume no i mean that yeah
that's pretty awesome i'm very impressed
with you
i know i'm really very impressed with
you
when you train with these guys who
trained keanu reeves for john wick it
seems like you're breaking your thumbs
you're breaking your ribs uh the
training is
intense and i'm and i'm like i thought
there's stunt people for that stuff why
are you damaging yourself i well you
don't set out to do that and it's very
it is very rare i have to say i mean
i've had
and even this some injury wasn't that
bad like even if a stunt person did this
it wouldn't have helped like i
grabbed onto a guy and my thumb got
stuck in his like
wardrobe and he turned and he just kind
of bent my thumb back with him
so i tore the ligament off the bone and
then i remembered the first action movie
i ever did was ian flux and i hurt
myself actually pretty bad on that
because
there was a level of like we want you to
be crazy supple because this anime
character that's not even real is like
you know constantly in the splits or
like you know in back bends and i was
like it's not i can't do that so they
put me with these cirque du soleil
people who were lovely but they were
double jointed and weird and i was like
i have three months like i'm not gonna
be able to like you know smell my own
[ __ ] in a backbend it's not gonna
happen so let's find something that i
can do but in a in flux you almost got
paralyzed you fell on your head or
something trying to do one of these
quacks because i have no business doing
back handsprings i'm not a gymnast
you're not gonna learn that in three
months so
this the i think now for me it's all
about having the right team you don't
need a stunt person to step in and do
something you create it to be something
that you can do and that's what makes it
fun when you have choreography that is
there to celebrate you as an actor to
tell the story not like make have a
stunned person step in to make you look
good it's like we're telling a story the
actor is doing it they've worked for
four months it's like rehearsal they
know exactly what they're doing that's
[ __ ] awesome when you can do that i'd
say if we count up the box off you're
now one of the number one action stars
for years you know was
somewhat frustrating for me as a woman
because i like the genre i like watching
these movies like i grew up my mom loved
chuck norris and charles bronson and
like it makes me feel
you know it makes me feel good about
just knowing that we've changed
that industry as a whole like i feel
like this genre has definitely had a
facelift and i feel like women have been
a huge part in that like i feel like
women have kind of like stepped up in
the genre and made it fun again and and
not made it
just part of this one conversation which
is like oh well women can't fight like
men well we don't want to [ __ ] fight
like men we want to fight like we would
fight
i mean i think this was real like when
you were shooting that prank and you
guys your dicks were in that um that
chinese um what do you call that chinese
finger drop the chinese finger trap it's
the funniest thing but it looked like
that guy really pulled a knife on you
was gonna kill you oh yeah and that was
rel's first day of shooting that was my
co-star's first day of shooting he never
had shot a hidden camera prank in his
life and i kept being like no no it's
okay we got a safety protocol it's going
to be fine
we walked into the safe what's the
weight is there what's the safety
protocol what do you have a safe word
we have a safe word if i know popcorn
that means you got to come in and save
me because i'm about to die why'd you
choose that word i wanted a word that i
would like never use in real life in a
scene the only time you say the word
popcorn is when you're ordering popcorn
so it's not like it couldn't be confused
with some you know something i was
saying like in the heat of the
performance so you say to your co-star
don't worry we got this thing down if
some something really dangerous happens
i yell popcorn everything's fine but
yeah of course you probably have never
yelled popcorn ever
i've never yelled it and things did not
go fine and then i got so nervous when
they so so we we went to this hood
barber shop with our dicks in a chinese
finger trap
the we asked that we we politely asked
the barber for scissors
and barbara was like oh hell no he
started looking for his gun
couldn't find his gun found his knife
chased this out of the thing with a
knife and we me and rel can barely run
in that thing because we're joined at
the dick so we're like
like laurel and hardy running out of
there
and then i was so nervous i forgot my
own safe word because i've never used it
so instead of yelling popcorn i was
yelling goosebumps so
no one knew what i was talking about i
was like goosebumps goosebumps
goosebumps just out of nerves and it was
like [ __ ] popcorn
and then my security guy jumped in and
did like a judo chop on the guy and grab
his knife
right and then we go hey you're in a
hidden camera prank thing and then he
was like oh y'all are hilarious
with that one
he went from like a murderous rage to
like slapping his knee
well that was the problem with also
doing the leg show and the movies was
that the kind of stakes became higher so
in bruno
you ended up being i ended up being in
situations where
i wouldn't say my life was in threat but
i was in danger of being hospitalized or
you know so
the the end scene in bruno is a cage
fight i don't know if you remember that
yeah and people were throwing chairs
yeah so
i remember when we were planning that
scene and you know coming back to the
original question of you know you come
up with a crazy idea in the room and
it's like you know how do we make this
happen and the idea was
i want to have the love scene where
bruno meets his boyfriend again
and they start kissing in the middle of
a cage fight and bruno's become this
really macho guy called straight dave
and he's pretending not to be gay you
know
and uh one of the greatest scenes ever
and basically you know i called up the
lawyer this the studio said you can't do
it it's illegal and i said why not and
they had their lawyers on the line they
said you're crossing state lines to have
a riot
and that is a federal offense you know
that that's what they arrested the
chicago seven for but you know it
becomes not just a state offense so so
you can't do that so i said well let's
see if we can do that let's you know
we're going to do it let's let's work
out how the lawyers told you not to do
it you said i'm going to do it i said
we're going to do it and we're going to
find out a legal way to do it and
doesn't that take a physical like
something out of you to do i mean
because you're nervous as i mean you
went into a cage you're making out with
another guy there's all these people in
the audience who have no idea yeah we
had we were like 300 people sure and one
of the referees said don't worry you
guys don't don't worry i'll get people
there he basically was a prison warden
and he got 300 ex-cons who'd just come
out and some of these guys come in
they've got swastikas on their heads
right and i'm there and i know i'm gonna
you know speak out with a guy and start
a riot and we had like this you know
this fence around and i had like
security around and i said all right you
know can anyone climb in and they go
don't worry no one can climb in right it
would take them three minutes anyway
meanwhile suddenly there's a fight in
the audience this my security disappear
and then the crowd start booing me
and the one thing i'm told by my lawyer
is don't ever don't incite a riot i
cannot say anything inside right and
suddenly they stopped booming i go all
right any of your mo any of your facts i
want to have the [ __ ] kicked out of you
come in here right now anyway i knew no
one could get into the cage why do you
think you did that because you said this
is going to be funny like even though
i'm going to be dead this is going to be
so funny at some point you don't think
at that point right at some point i tell
you what you get so deep into character
that you kind of lost you get lost and i
got lost and it was the most stupid
thing obviously do you think you'll ever
go out and risk your life like that
again i would love to do it again i
don't want to risk my life you know and
you know even when i was risking my life
i was always very calculated you know
right you don't look at it as risking
your life i i was always trying to
minimize the risk so for example you
know
when you go in a room with was it ron
paul who you started coming on to yes
has anyone ever told you look like
enrique iglesias
you figured hey you could take him he
can't get you up right yeah that's
calculated yeah but it's you know so for
example if we were going into a redneck
bar i'd find out you know from my
security i'd go what percentage of
people have guns and then
you know you try and take you know you
have the sound guy
you know touch them a little bit and see
if they had guns isn't that true yeah
you do that you can size up the room to
see if people have guns yeah you try and
find out the problem is in the south you
can't you can't take people's guns off
them it's like asking a guy to remove
his underpants whatever i remember we
did one scene where
it was a bunch of hunters in arkansas
again arkansas was a great place it was
crazy when you're in the tent and you
try to get into you sneak into their
tent naked yeah exactly so and they're
like gonna kill you yeah and so i said
my security guard i go
you know
with bruno we had to use security before
that we never used security and i just
said all right take their guns off them
and i go the gun's off and he goes no
they they won't take their guns
so i said all right fine so you know
we're around the campfire look at the
far fast we have saw likes of saxons and
city girls
oh no we aren't either
and uh they basically realized i was gay
right right and
they got really fidgety and one of them
they basically go off and they got their
guns
and they loaded their guns
we're in a dark field in the middle of
arkansas yeah and they've got loaded
guns i'm sitting in there sitting around
a campfire
and i know them and i know that the next
scene is i'm gonna go in naked into
their tent
and they've got guns they're loaded so
it's you know it gets nervous
was the most dangerous thing you do in
jackass 3d when you uh almost broke your
neck is that is that the
is that the the stunt so to speak
i tried to roller skate in a buffalo
herd too what is that
it's a roger miller song that i tried to
bring to life you tried to roller skate
into a buffalo yeah all right and what
happened there well roger miller was
absolutely correct you cannot roller
skate in a buffalo hurt they knocked the
cow walking [ __ ] out of me
buffalo hit into you there was i there
was uh three are they stampeding at that
point yes and they hit you full on yes
and your body's thrown around like a rag
doll and that's where you almost broke
it and that was right after i did the
invisible man so i almost break my neck
and then i'm like i go dust myself off
change clothes and then get run over by
some buffalo how many how many days in
between the stunts
no there was uh maybe an hour and a half
between the stunts hour and a half yeah
what's the invisible man that's when i
paint myself into a background yeah in
but in the middle of a
bullring the bull attacks you i got
flipped up in the air right before i hit
the ground the bull kicked me in the
head and it altered my course just
enough where it honestly helped me no
fear when you go and do that yeah
there's fear
what what is the rush because you're
getting in on film and you're going man
millions of people are going to laugh at
this and i and i feel good about it uh
but the right i just after you shoot it
and then me and my friend sit around and
look at the footage and laugh but
there's no real way of knowing if you'll
get killed or not i mean there's no real
way the first time you do it no there's
no no you don't know what's going to
happen really you know the bull is going
to try and smoke you but you don't know
but the stunt isn't successful unless
you get hit when you're roller skating
and bulls are stampeding right and they
hit you that's the humor
and you know you're going to have to get
hit if it's going to be funny and
successful and in fact if you get really
thrown it's going to be funny and if
anything short of dying will be funny
yeah dying gets a little dark but uh you
know which of those takes do you do i
mean retakes of these they don't work
yeah there's retakes like i did a thing
where i tried to catch a pass over the
middle
uh and i'd had jared allen of the
minnesota vikings hit me yeah while i
was you know jumping up to catch the
ball and we shot that three times and he
hits hard he's like six six and he was
smoking me every time but it wasn't i
could tell it wasn't
what i wanted or we wanted
and be like okay let's do it again is
there any technique involved in this so
that you don't get hurt or is it just
like i'll just throw myself up there and
see what happens well you gotta you
gotta commit and you gotta go in with
the good uh point of view if you get
like real negative and you half commit
and then that's when you're really going
to get
you don't get hurt you're going to get
injured